all right guys
bang bang special treat today i have
fidei guy here what's up man
what's going on what's going on thanks
for having me all right the first time
that i came across you
uh i'll just you know mindlessly
scrolling through twitter
and then all of a sudden i saw i think
it was a music video
with a fire beat and all i remember
is you were just trolling about oil
going
negative and i was like wait wait wait
wait wait what
and uh so you got to tell us before we
get into the music
what is your background how the hell did
you get into this
rapping about finance is not exactly the
thing that i think most people
grow up dreaming to do yeah oh totally
um
yeah look i've been rapping ever since i
was you know in middle school i just
always had
uh you know an interest in it i think
the part about
rap that like really interested me as
like a kid and like has kind of kept me
interested is
not so much like you know the club type
music
i just love uh you know the people that
are like truly poets
that know how to take a concept and know
how to talk about things in a way that
you know using metaphors and similes
really engaging people
uh you know through music and in a way
you know for them it's a craft and
there's people that are phenomenal at
that crap
you know nas j cole i look at these guys
as like they're genuinely poets you know
and i grew up like listening to them
and i did it you know my whole life but
it was really informal you know it was
at parties
it was hanging out my friends long car
rides etc
you know got to college eventually was
doing it at you know at parties or
you know uh at the frat house whatever
um and eventually started working and i
kind of felt like rap and
you know the corporate wall street world
literally had you know nothing in common
and so i kept it a huge secret i kind of
fell out of it a little bit
but i started to feel like you know
there's just part of me that's this
creative side that i feel like has kind
of been like suppressed a little bit
i've been so focused on work
and i was like i gotta get back into
this and i'm like i'm in
new york city of all places like if you
can't get into it here
or try to make something happen here
you're shot right
so there was uh this freestyle group you
know a couple blocks down from me in
union square
and a buddy of mine saw their video and
he's like you gotta go check this out
literally went there from work i had
like the typical like midtown uniform on
i have like a dress shirt on dress pants
like a vest
it was like the middle of october uh and
i go there
and it's this huge group of people they
just play a beat and everybody's
freestyling improvising playing off each
other i'm like dude this is sick
but like this is another level and like
i'm not sure if i'm like ready for it
but i was like you know what like i've
been doing this for a while
i gotta get into it i gotta just kind of
bite the bullet and go and uh you know i
had a good session there and that kind
of ignited this like
you know uh reignited my passion for it
uh and i was doing the freestyle thing
and eventually got to a point where look
like
you know i work in bank in banking now
there's not a lot of things i can talk
about that
are typically in rap songs that anybody
is going to resonate with if
i talk about you know what do i know
what worlds can i blend
uh i kind of just fell into the starting
to blend finance into rap
and you know enough people kind of
gravitated towards it to where you know
i've been keeping it going and
you know luckily i've had a lot of fun
with it so far all right so
what what is this group it's just like
in the park and people just play a beat
and literally just a bunch of folks
standing around
uh and kind of one after the other start
freestyling
exactly yeah it's called legendary
ciphers they started it
probably over a decade ago every friday
from uh may through november you know
they gather in the same spot
in union square you know anybody's
welcome to go the good part about union
square is the high traffic area people
going to the subway commuting leaving
work so there's always an audience
and it's literally anybody that wants to
step up uh
they just play a bunch of instrumentals
and people just wrap rap
back and forth and kind of like the
coolest thing about it honestly is
it is these people that are like have
such different lives that you would
never think
had things in common all interacting
together people from
europe people from white collar america
people from blue collar america people
from the suburbs people from urban areas
everybody's there because they love
music and they share this passion
um and it's awesome and people are just
feeding off of each other you know
someone brings up an idea
somebody else talks about it it morphs
into a new idea people come people
beatbox people sing
you know photographers come it's it's
like this amazing community thing that's
all built on
you know a shared love for this uh you
know for this for this art
i love it uh so you get the uh renewed
interest and kind of passion uh and then
what gave you the idea what was the
song where you mentioned the the oil
prices uh
was that the first one that you did that
wasn't kind of a freestyle was more like
a produced song
uh so i actually did the one before that
uh it was called
it was called stocks dropping so this
guy this guy jack harlow
made like this incredible song scott
platinum he's like remixed it with lil
wayne and everybody
uh called what's poppet right song was
like trending
it was like one of the top songs in
america the beat was like absolutely
phenomenal
um and this is like peak covey when like
they basically declared you know
new york city everybody's working from
home right i was like
this is the perfect opportunity to make
a good video there's so much going on
and i basically remix what's popping
with like stops dropping
uh it's like just work from home ask
them about working in finance and like
the stock drop the stock market
dropping and ways to play it and whatnot
uh you know it was like kind of goofy i
was wearing
like a blazer with shorts you know we
shot it outside all the stores were
closed
uh and i think the interest in that one
really kind of
you know gave me a pulse of hey like
this resonates with people
you know this is a an underrepresented
community
in the hip-hop world you know uh and
something that
a lot of people don't talk about and i
think um you know everybody wants
representation
right and so there's this huge corporate
world finance business world
uh that obviously has an identity that
has interested music
and so i think parlaying those two
together you know really touched on
you know a niche that i think people
people are into and it really kind of
galvanized
you know the momentum of hey people like
this um
you know and i i've kind of kept going
and uh luckily uh it's gone well so far
when you created this song it's you and
a friend it's just all you like like
talk to me about the
the process the process of actually
creating these yeah
it's gotten a little bit uh more
official now but the first one was
literally
uh you know my best friend from college
um
you know unfortunately for me he was on
track to go to med school realize that
you know his whole family's doctors he
just realized like
you know i've been doing it i feel like
maybe there's pressure to do it but i
don't necessarily it's not my passion
and he kind of abandoned that track and
went full-on
uh music it's like audio engineering
producing
which is good for me because now i have
someone i'm super close with who's
plugged into that world right
so the first song we did it was covered
couldn't go anywhere i had no equipment
i'd literally recorded just the audio
the vocals
um on my phone right like in the iphone
record
he's enough of a stud where he was able
to take that put that on top of the beat
you know do all his layering and whatnot
to make it sound decent
and my other roommate literally with an
iphone we just took like a very like
low budget backyard video put it all
together i like downloaded a free trial
of like adobe
you know editor uh made it on the
computer um
and dropped it and um you know we've
gotten a little bit more
uh you know official now i bought a
microphone
you know you realize how ridiculous that
sounds right
you're saying you got official because
you got a microphone yeah
so it beats it definitely beats the
audio quality of a cell phone
so you know got a microphone you know
got some better equipment
um and i can do it now in person with
him so i think that's been a big help
and i think it's chosen the quality
and then um you know i've worked with a
guy now that shoots legitimate video to
try to help the quality
of the videos but i think there is
something about that uh
you know kind of hits people in a
certain way when they can just tell it's
like a backyard production you know
just kind of someone put this together
like with five dollars
um that kind of hits so uh
i don't know if you know this story but
um i'm assuming that you know
uh little dickie right yeah yeah he
um a friend of mine or somebody i knew
in college not really a friend but
somebody knew in college
uh i think was actually his roommate uh
when he was creating like the original
videos in san francisco
i know a guy that was his roommate in
college too okay so this was
uh a girl okay so maybe they were all
roommates or different times or whatever
uh small world though but yeah yeah but
what i remember is like i remember
seeing the video and then she told me
she was like oh yeah like that like
that's a
uh my roommate and i'm pretty sure it's
roommate maybe it was a friend or
whatever
um what was so interesting was it was
this low budget
uh whole thing right it was like
basically being filmed
uh you know with no real equipment and
it was just like hey i've got this skill
uh and an interest in doing this like
we're just gonna do it
right and i think that you're right and
that that resonates well with people
when they uh when they just see like
oh the the quality of this is not in the
production value it's an actual person
themselves right mm-hmm
totally totally um yeah it's funny you
mentioned like little dicky because
like before i dropped anything i was
like all right like who can i kind of
study that's like done this already and
to kind of take some lessons
and i remember watching him on like one
of the talk shows like the late night
talk shows talking about
like his process and he basically was
like you know he was in school i think
he went to richmond which was like
a very good school um you know and he
has his
he's saved up all this bar mitzvah money
um
and his parents like what the hell are
you doing he's like i gotta take the
money
i'm gonna make this video gotta produce
it uh you know and he put
you know not crazy budget bar mitzvah
money type budget
um you know into it went to bed woke up
and had a million views on youtube
and then you know nothing's been the
same since um crazy
yeah insane insane and i think you know
he hit it at a good time where
everybody now is trying to make videos
and there's you know the market is
definitely
very saturated yeah i think he anybody
that had that insight to kind of
leverage you know youtube and any
platform at an early
and early days has you know clearly
reaped the benefits of that
absolutely um and so talk to me about
like stocks dropping right you obviously
got kind of the uh the commodity stuff
then
uh you recently did one where uh you
went literally to wall street and uh
and you were doing like the instead of
the ten crack commandments you were
basically doing like the ten
uh commandments of financial education
um
what's kind of the goal here right
because it's all finance related but is
it to educate people is it just to
make hot songs like what talk about like
what like what are you optimizing for
totally um you know
i think i definitely started it to try
to have a good time right um
and you know even going to like that
freestyle group
you know it's funny like people can kind
of
get a sense of like who you are you know
what you do
what you stand for and like when you
kind of touch on those things
people just kind of uh it resonates more
right
so you know i go to these rap groups
we're talking about whatever under the
sun right
but then like every time i would touch
on like something financial i'd mention
like a 401k
like literally and it's in like some of
the like the freestyle videos i have
posted
people be like yeah spit that financial
[ __ ]
you know like it was just like that's
your thing you know so i was like
as much as like rap and finance aren't
necessarily related at least in you know
a responsible way um you know
people [ __ ] with it so uh i always
kind of kept that in the back of my mind
right
and so i was making these videos and
they were all fun um
and i was trying to figure out like okay
do i appeal to like high finance like i
think the how crude video was like
you know you're talking about contango
you're talking about storage supply and
demand it's not
your your light person doesn't know that
right um
and i kind of thought you know the
attention that it gets the people that
listen
like maybe there's an opportunity here
to parlay the two interests
parlay the rap with the finance you know
rap is a way a much more digestible
piece of information
than someone trying to lecture you on
finance right finance is boring
people don't know about finance because
it's a lack of education but people
aren't driven to learn about it because
it's boring right um
and so i think that you know that
realization was like hey maybe there's a
way to
you know combine those two and i think
you know while the biggie song obviously
has certain applications i think people
derive a lot more value from learning
about financial principles and learning
about how to sell crap right and so my
you know my thought was
let's take this classic song that
everyone knows about
and kind of tailor it not towards high
finance but towards
you know everybody right and what i've
observed in this whole process
um is there's so many people that are
highly educated
you know they're they're employed
they've graduated universities they have
masters
um they don't know basics about
investing they don't even have any money
invested they're like
yeah i just have my money in a savings
account they don't know what an etf is a
mutual fund like basic
101. um and it was kind of that
realization that maybe i can take
you know the music and use that as uh
you know kind of an introduction to get
people interested
i love you know i want to make hot
tracks i want to make good music i want
to make good songs
um but it's also that realization that
like you know i've been fortunate enough
to be in a position to learn about these
things
that can enhance my quality of life you
know it can enhance everybody's quality
of life
and maybe this is the way um you know
the medium
to kind of get people interested uh and
to kind of spread that knowledge
for sure and it feels like uh this is
well you're like really focused on it
and it's kind of you know literally from
your name
to uh the actual content uh
there's still a kind of macro trend
right so when you see you know jay-z and
444 right talking about you know hey i
should have bought that building in
dumbo right or talking about the
appreciation of private art
um you just start to see this attitude
from
uh kind of the things that can make you
money in the streets as
these guys have gotten much older uh
kind of wiser
they've actually got capital to invest
now now they're actually starting to
talk about
uh maybe not personal finance but
definitely talking more about investing
and kind of those benefits and so it
feels like
um there's always been this like
reception because if the best people in
the world are doing it right then it
kind of trickles down
and then you come along and you've got
you know this is my message
like people are almost just like waiting
for that type of content right yeah i
agree completely and i think a big part
you know
why that is like more of a trending
topic
is because you know you know the wealth
disparity now
is you know is enormous and i think a
lot of what people are realizing is
what's driving that that disparity
you know is not people's salaries right
it's whether they're investing in
financial asset
the way that you know the stock market
um you know is driving you know the
stock market
uh you know growing is increasing
people's wealth
in a way that you know your paycheck or
your salary or
you know whatever a small side hustle
can't necessarily do right and so i
think people are like wait you know
if these people are getting uber rich
you know mega rich why aren't doing
something like this you know the way to
compete is to have those financial
assets and to
you know and to ride that trend and i
think people you know are realizing that
now
uh more than ever um and you know i
think
a big thing is too for people is this
hesitation with like you know i've only
got 500 bucks is that enough and it's
like
the point is like you just got to start
with anything right you could start with
10
right if you can find you know find
someone that knows
some of the basics you just get started
you know you don't put
everything in at once but you learn like
you do with anything right you start off
slow
you don't put a ton of capital at risk
um but you know you develop a plan i'm
going to put x amount a month i'm going
to buy the s
p once i'm comfortable with buying the s
p maybe i'll diversify internationally
you know
um but i think for people it's just
getting started um
you know i've seen you know firsthand in
a lot of ways
you know my both of my parents were um
you know entrepreneurs
you know my dad started his own uh my
dad was in healthcare but started his
own practice my mom was in healthcare
started her own company
you know there was a time where they
were doing extremely well
um you know but they didn't know about
like
you know at that level these for the
people that are highly educated didn't
know about
you know building a diversified
portfolio having that compound
having retirement assets right and i've
seen that like kind of firsthand
and so for me i've been hyper focused on
you know
starting young is adds so many benefits
um and you know and and kind of having
that in the back of your mind
you know creating a plan and trying to
stick to that you know it can it can
literally change your life you know over
over time
um and i think more people need to need
to know about that
um yeah absolutely and talk a little bit
about
uh you know you mentioned how you're
creating the content where are you
distributing it and kind of where have
you seen
uh the most receptivity in terms of uh
is it youtube is it twitter is it other
platforms and kind of how you think
about the the various platforms
yeah uh definitely for me it was
instagram just because that's where i
built like the initial base
uh have been trying to diversify out of
that um and you know get it on different
platforms
um i think the you know what instagram
has going for especially for like
content creators is that like it's
highly visual
um you know you can post longer videos
um
you know and it's very easy for people
to uh to share
to share content same with twitter but
twitter's you know inherently
it's more text based right instagram's
highly visual
um but you know i've started to send out
to to youtube
start to send out to twitter um you know
but a big thing too is i want to kind of
create
songs that are just songs and put those
on spotify but i think you know in
today's day and age i really do think
it's
uh you know a multi-dimensional approach
but for what i've been doing so far i
think the
it's resonated the most on on instagram
for sure
got it um and then in terms of the
actual
skill of rapping like there's a lot of
people gonna listen to this and think oh
you're just born with it
like are you born with it can you get
better at it you know talk a little bit
just about like the actual
craft of you know using words and uh you
know used to work poetry earlier
in terms of then layering that with
music and how you think about it
totally uh it's actually pretty funny so
i'm like the guy that tries to get all
my friends
to rap right so like the biggest thing
that we do is like
we'll like take uber's like if we're
going out doing whatever we'll take
uber's
and we're always like all right let's
put a beat on let's put a beat up
and like it's not fun to just sit there
and rap alone right so i try to get
everybody
comfortable i'm like look it doesn't
matter if you're good or bad like the
point is like like anything
just just try figure it out right so
it's funny it's like
friends that are like not about it at
all like
over the years have gotten into it to
the point where like well we will be in
the car let's say it's four of us
and like me and one guy like are going
back and forth
the other friend who's like more shy was
like dude i do not rap i'll never do it
i'd be like all right check it you know
and he'll like come in out of nowhere
so it's awesome um and i do think you
know do people have a higher propensity
for it you know
sure but i do think it's just like
anything you know if you
i think people can get better at it um
the key is like practicing
find people that are into it that don't
like kind of beat you down it's like
it's not that good
but i've encouraged all my friends to to
wrap to freestyle i feel like
you know i help them get better they
help me get better
and it's just fun you know it it's fun
um
i think the hardest part that people
have is not necessarily coming up with
the words
but it's figuring out how to kind of
like flow and ride on the beat
and that just kind of comes in practice
comes like listening to some of the guys
that are the greats
and like anything you know there's a
pattern uh and once you kind of figure
out the way that dates are constructed
how there's like you know
you know units of measurement you know
transitions happen at certain times
and you kind of figure that out that'll
that'll definitely help you but i have
one buddy
uh my my buddy needs he's in california
right now um
he'll get a kick out of this but he's
like since college you know he's been
the guy that's like
he's like like you know i'm not bad but
like i want to keep doing this and get
better and then now like literally he'll
like
he'll call me out of the blue i was like
hey what's up man he's like dude i know
you're busy at work i just had to hit
you up
like i just had this rap in the shower
it was phenomenal i got to show it to
you right and he gets all excited about
it and i think that you know
other people around kind of see that too
so he's calling you after the shower
while you're at work just telling you
what raps he just hit in the shower
yeah exactly he's like super hyped for
that i love it so you know it's great
it's great
that's awesome um what what's what's
your goal
right in terms of uh where do you want
this to go is this something that you're
like hey
you know i want to blow this up and uh
have come kind of a full-time focus
is it something that you just enjoyed
doing on the side but you know see kind
of a career in finance like
how do you think about you and how you
spend your day
uh moving forward totally um
i think what's good about you know i'll
call this a side hustle i think what's
good about this
side hustle for me in particular is that
you know
it's not completely separated from what
i do i get my day job right
you know some people that you know if
they build furniture but then they work
at a bank
it's not really much overlap i think
what's good is that you know working in
finance
being in the industry gives me a lot of
insights
kind of helps me parlay that into you
know excuse me
uh into the fidei guy stuff so i think
it'd be great to kind of try to balance
it too ultimately what i kind of
envisioned it in
an ideal world you know it would be
creating a platform that is
you know focused on music but that kind
of branches out beyond that you know
it's having conversations like this
where the music is kind of the draw you
know and hopefully i can make
songs that people genuinely you know
listen to and enjoy
and they don't all have to be super
financy right they could touch on
anything but maybe incorporating
elements of a
business into it uh by really creating a
platform where people that
enjoy music you know people that want to
be educated on finance or kind of be
um you know kept in the loop with what's
going on in the financial community
kind of a place where they can come and
experience both
and i think you know my reach goal like
you know
i think the milestone where i'm like
okay like i kind of made it
is like if i can um you know somehow
collaborate with like david solomon
who's a ceo of goldman sachs e.j diesel
uh he's like commented on one of my
videos you know he's answered some dms
but i think you know i can get to a
point where you know we can do something
together i think that'd be like the
pinnacle of like
finance and music um and you know i
think
that would be awesome i'm going to hold
you to it now i'm expecting a d
soul fight eye guy charity uh concert
when uh when all this is over yeah trust
me i'm trying i'm
damn that guy right sorry for you know
blowing you up but he's answered a few
times so
yeah him and uh what is it uh the guy
jeffrey's a rich handler i think he
yeah he's active he's super active on uh
on instagram too and uh
i think it's great you know it's that's
where you know if you're trying to
communicate with people and you know
build your brand as an individual
and like someone that's approachable
it's down to earth you know that's the
way to do it no one's gonna
they you're not gonna convey your
personality at a board meeting you know
yeah uh i think i got turned onto rich
because uh he posted from like the
trading floor
uh like a fit tee uh photo like he had
like the fit that you know like the
instagram models do and he was like
yeah yeah like like basically like i
think i made it right or whatever and i
guess his daughter got him to do it
uh he was like dude the ceo of jeffries
is doing 50 posts from the trading floor
i was like that's pretty cool it's
awesome though right yeah of course
well because i think also it's a it's
the authenticity and it also just shows
like hey look you know
these folks aren't kind of you know our
parents or our parents parents
uh kind of executives meaning that it
was you know all business all the time
right they have a personality they kind
of
uh really show that look like they want
to have fun as well right and they may
do it in their own way but
um you know who would have thought the
ceo of goldman sachs would be
uh would be out you know djing at like
legit
clubs and events and like it's not like
he's doing it at home
he's like with a legitimate artist yeah
it's awesome yeah so
i think all that's cool um in terms of
the message
what exactly like if you could just wave
a magic wand and kind of get any message
across
what do you think that is from a
financial education standpoint for uh
from us folks
[Music]
i think it would probably be
you know there's basic financial
principles
that are easy to understand that every
person
should know that can
radically increase your quality of life
right i don't think finance needs to be
some esoteric thing that only a few
people understand that that are in that
universe
you know finance you know finances money
whatever you want to call it investments
affects every single person you know in
this country
um you know you should understand the
basics because they have a huge impact
in your life
you know there's ways to get that
information in a way that's
you know easily digestible um and it has
huge impacts
um in your life you know you may not see
it today
you may not see it tomorrow you know
five ten years down the road you'll kind
of see the value
of of being educated you know putting
money to work letting your money work
for you
um and you know no amount is too small
you know the key is just
uh to get started yeah i think it's a
great piece of uh
piece of advice um and then what's kind
of the next step
in terms of we talked about your
ultimate goal and and kind of what's the
next step down that path is it just
creating more
uh content and getting it out on
platforms or
anything in the works that people should
be aware of
yeah i think for now you know the focus
is on still trying to make
content you know create additional um
you know create music and create videos
but i'm also trying to
create additional resources so for
example like for the ten commandments
you know i also wrote a blog post where
i kind of um
you know touched on all those
commandments and tried to expand upon
them for anybody that was you know
curious to learn more um and you know i
think
you know a great thing would be to work
with you know certain organizations to
work with certain people
that have you know an additional
platform um you know that have
uh re resources uh and to work with them
to kind of further disseminate
you know not not just the content but to
kind of disseminate the information
right i think it'd be great to get to a
point where
um you know it's i want to get invested
you know how do i get started is there
anything that you know is a good thing
for me to do
as i'm getting started and to be able to
point them in a good direction with
people that are
that are happy to work with them yeah
that's awesome uh i told you to uh
to to bring some uh some music you got
music for us you gotta
give me any uh any rhymes i got some
bars i got some bars
all right okay
he's currently pulling it up on his
phone for those that are not watching
he makes i had to talk some water
all right i know just for the time sake
i'm gonna hit when i i'm gonna give you
the
the uh thumbs up when i hit the hit the
play button
[Music]
okay listen
it's crazy what you achieve when you
believe simply roll up your sleeves and
see there's magic underneath
for example i'm sitting here with mr
pompliano make me want to celebrate as
if it's feliz coons
chilling here with pomp going crazy on
this podcast spitting prior dropping
blonde face accumulating knowledge
that you would never learn in college my
mission is not stopping till my current
conditions abolish
i'm polished i acknowledge that it might
be encrypted currently but listen to
this man when it comes to cryptocurrency
he's basically got a phd in these assets
he's been on the move pushing through
these tax brackets
money it don't do nothing under your
mattress inflation will eat away at you
and the fact is everyone could benefit
from information so listen to my boss
for fuego and some basic education
that is fantastic it is very obvious
that if you could do that and teach
people people will pay attention
yeah thanks man i appreciate you yeah go
ahead
no we're gonna say no i didn't just say
that i i i genuinely appreciate you know
you having me on and you
you know reposting the videos on twitter
and helping to get the word out there
and
you know spread the content so you know
listen
uh i i told you before we started i love
it i literally when i saw the very first
one
i think you were sitting in like your
living room or something and you were uh
rapping about the commodities i was
dying laughing and i was like dude we
need more people listening to this
and i think you're right that most
people probably had no clue what you
were talking about but they were just
like hey this song's hot
all right when i saw you came out with
the uh
the ten commandments i was like oh this
is where people are going to get
educated so it makes a ton of sense and
i think you're right in that it takes
somebody who's got the uh the music
kind of background right and is talented
and can kind of produce good content
but then you also need people who
understand uh finance right and so
there's probably not that many people
who
kind of have that overlap which is uh
which is great kind of path for you to
blaze
before i let you go rapid fire questions
man first up most important book
oh um
um i think a good one for me is the art
of happiness
by uh the dalai lama and uh i forget the
other
the other author why uh i think it just
sets
an amazing example and and gives you
really good
uh you know lessons for how to navigate
things that are inevitable to happen in
your life you know i thought a really
good
piece of that was you know in today's
world people see
you know people suffer in some way or
they have some challenge and they think
that they're an outlier
and you know he talks about listen to
live and to exist is to
endure you know some type of pain
challenge suffering
no matter what you see online everybody
goes through that every day right and i
thought that was just
awesome advice for how to deal better
with you know all the curveballs that
life throws at you
that's that's a great answer uh aliens
believer or non-believer
100 percent believe well that's right
unequivocally
you know there's just too much out there
there's too many planets too many suns
too many solar systems for
you know the pieces not to be right in
some way
to create some system either like ours
or like something else and i think
our comprehension of what's in the
universe and how it actually works
is so small relative to what's actually
out there there's no way that somebody
can say
uh that they're not out there somewhere
it's very fair i tend to uh i tend to
agree with that as people know
uh before i let you ask me one question
to finish up
uh shout out tom shaughnessy who uh
who's the one who
ultimately connected boy the guy shared
the video and then
and then he connected us which uh i have
no clue how you two know each other but
uh of course tom knows you
yeah yeah mutual friend from uh from
college
got it uh and then uh what question you
got for me to finish up
let's see uh i guess what is your what
is your biggest motivation
in uh and what you do
i have my personal motivation and then i
have like kind of the the reason why i
do everything that i'm doing
uh personally like i just enjoy it right
like it
you know i always joke with people and
they're like what do you do and i'm like
i'm happy you're like no what do you do
and i'm like no you you're missing the
point here like i'm just happy
right and i forget where where i got
that quote from um
but but it's this this idea of like to
me i'm going to keep doing this stuff
until one day i will wake up one day and
just like it's over
see you right and people wait what do
you mean i was like
no like literally i'm not creating
content today yeah
yeah yeah it's not like yo in two weeks
this is gonna be over it's like no
today's the day like see you
uh so i think that's it in terms of like
the the
bigger motivation of like why this stuff
um i just fundamentally believe that
uh educating people on the way money
works how the economy works and kind of
just
personal finance in general uh is
probably the number one thing we can do
to create a more equitable world
right so like you can do all the
philanthropy in the world like i just
don't believe that that's how you solve
the problems i think it's by giving
education to people and like teaching
them to fish
um is a major piece of that uh then
you've got to restructure the system
right which is why i'm so interested in
bitcoin
um and then yes the philanthropy stuff
can help
it's just that you know are you trying
to solve kind of the short term and do
pain mitigation where are you going more
for
long-term impact and actually kind of
changing
um you know the system so that you can
affect more people i tend to
be much more drawn to the larger scale
things rather than just the
individual things that's awesome um i
thought of another question actually
all right um what's like the
the most absurd like dm
or message that you've like received on
like any of your platforms
that's a good one um i mean there's like
absurd can be defined many ways like
there's the like death threat type stuff
right which is like pretty absurd i'm
just like what
uh it's like there's that stuff uh
lately i've been getting lots of
uh please sir uh can you send me you
know five hundred dollars in bitcoin
uh and you go and you look and it's like
a handle that's got like 17
000 numbers at the end of it uh so it's
just like obviously a bot
um but but uh that
um the most absurd one that i can
probably
talk about uh
i'll put it this way there's a couple of
people i'm thinking of three in
particular they're all billionaires
that like randomly dm to me
uh and these are all different times
they come from different industries
whatever but like each time that's
happened
i just been like what planet am i living
on right like
like legitimately like what planet am i
living on um
and they're absurd because it's a
reminder not so much like i don't get
like
star struck right instead it's the exact
opposite it's just like
it's a reminder that we're all on the
same playing field but the internet is a
great equalizer
right and so it's just like you've got
an account i've got an account so does
everybody else
and like it doesn't matter who you are
or whatever like you still have
quote-unquote access to people
now does it help that somebody knows
it's you versus me versus somebody else
yeah of course right
but the the idea that like this
equalizer of the internet i think it
just hits me in those moments where
you're like
this is crazy you know like wait for
this person to directly
interact with you yeah and and also it's
like somebody that you wouldn't normally
come in contact with
right so even if you were like trying to
get to them like it would be weird
and then it also like you balance it
with like that person who sent you
like the death threat versus the person
who's asking for 500 on bitcoin versus
you know the billionaire they're all the
same they all just have an account
right they come from super different
walks of life like all stuff but it's
just like the internet's great equalizer
so
i think that's probably when you're just
like whoa right that's awesome
yeah i think uh even gary v touches on
that it's like
if you were in the 80s trying to get in
touch with
some billionaire right you'd have to
call their secretary call their agent
your call would never get through
but it's like now you know you're on the
internet everyone has their profile and
you can theoretically get a message from
anybody
right so absolutely where where can we
send people to uh
to uh subscribe download consume
whatever you want them to do totally um
so on all the socials
it's uh at underscore fidei guy because
someone someone took
at fidei guy so if you type inside i got
i'm sure it'll pop up but the actual
handle is at underscore fidei guy
i have a website too where i post some
additional content it's where the blog
post is with the ten commandments
explained that's just fivebyguy.com and
you can
subscribe there as well i've been
starting a newsletter to try to again
combine rap music you know insights
news uh etc so you can subscribe there
as well and i'm on instagram
youtube twitter uh as the same handle so
awesome man fidei guy i love the name
you're crushing it
thank you so much for doing this thanks
for having me man really appreciate it